[Musique]
beaucoup en martinique la mer c'est ça
des eaux claires à 26° idéale pour la
baignade et les activités nautiques en
tout genre mais pour d'autres elle est
une source de revenus parfois la seule
qui permette de vivre de plus en plus
attractive
la mère a vu ces dernières années se
diversifier ses activités économiques
mais à quel prix la ressource subi des
agressions récurrentes liées à
l'activité humaine serviettes
hygiéniques aussi les habitats se
dégrade et la biodiversité marine est
menacé depuis quelques années les
mesures de protection se multiplient au
détriment parfois des pratiques
ancestrales
c'est pénible mais quelle est la
cohabitation entre les usagers de la mer
reste parfois problématique
[Musique]